[Music]
dating back at least to the time of
Socrates some early societies decided
that certain disputes such as whether a
person committed a particular crime
should be heard by a group of citizens
several centuries later trial by jury
was introduced to England where it
became a fundamental feature of the
legal system
checking the government and involving
citizens in decision-making juries
decided whether defendants would be
tried on crimes determined whether the
accused defendants were guilty and
resolved monetary disputes
while the American colonies eventually
cast off England's rule it's legal
tradition of the jury persistent the
United States Constitution instructed a
grand jury to decide whether criminal
cases proceeded required a jury to try
all crimes except impeachment and
provided for juries in civil cases as
well yet in the u.s. today grand juries
often are not convened and juries decide
less than four percent of criminal cases
and less than one percent of civil cases
filed in court that's at the same time
as jury systems in other countries are
growing so what happened in the u.s.
part of the story lies in how the
Supreme Court has interpreted the
Constitution it's permitted plea
bargaining which now occurs in almost
every criminal case the way it works is
a prosecutor presents the accused with a
decision of whether to plead guilty if
they accept a plea the case won't go in
front of a jury
but they'll receive a shorter prison
sentence than they'd get if a jury did
convicted the risk of a much greater
prison sentence after a trial can
frighten even an innocent defendant into
taking a plea between the 19th century
and the 21st century the proportion of
guilty pleas has increased from around
20 percent to 90 percent and the numbers
continue to grow the Supreme Court has
permitted the use of another procedure
that interferes with a jury called
summary judgment using summary judgment
judges can decide that civil trials are
unnecessary if the people who sue have
insufficient evidence this is intended
only for cases where no reasonable jury
would disagree
that's a difficult thing to determine
yet usage of summary judgment has
stretched to the point where some would
argue it's being abused
for instance judges grant fully or in
part over 70% of employers request to
dismiss employment discrimination cases
in other cases both the person who sues
and the person who defends forego their
right to go to court instead resolving
their dispute through a professional
arbitrator these are generally lawyers
professors or former judges arbitration
can be a smart decision by both parties
to avoid the requirements of a trial in
court but it's often agreed to
unwittingly when people signed contracts
like employment applications and
consumer agreements that can become a
problem for example some arbitrators may
be biased towards the companies that
give them cases these are just some of
the ways in which juries have
disappeared but could the disappearance
of juries be a good thing well juries
aren't perfect they're costly
time-consuming and may make errors and
they're not always necessary like when
people can simply agree to settle their
dispute but juries have their advantages
when properly selected jurors are more
representative of the general population
and don't have the same incentives as
prosecutors legislators or judges
seeking re-election or promotion the
founders of the United States trusted in
the wisdom of impartial groups of
citizens to check the power of all three
branches of government and the jury
trial itself has given ordinary citizens
a central role in upholding the social
fabric so will the jury system in the
u.s. survive into the future
[Music]